is somehow instantaneously affected or that the state of the two Qubits can't be described separately
or that the two Qubits
somehow maintain a memory of one another or even that
they're emotionally attached in some way.
But why are those properties
not true for this state?
These two bits are intimately connected, each one has a perfect
memory of the other one in a literal sense, but
it's not an entangled state.
Well, one way to explain what
makes entanglement special and what makes this state
very different from this state is to explain what we
can do with entanglement
or what we can see happening
because of entanglement that goes beyond the decisions we make about how we represent our
knowledge using vectors.
All three of the examples
that we'll discuss in this lesson have this nature in that they illustrate
things that we can do with entanglement that we
cannot do with this state
or with any classically correlated state.
Indeed, it's very typical in the study of quantum information and computation that we view entanglement as a resource
through which different
tasks can be accomplished.
And when we do that, we view this state as representing
one unit of entanglement.
We refer to this unit of
entanglement as an e-bit, the e stands for
entangled or entanglement.
It's true that it's two Qubits, but as a quantity of
entanglement, it's one e-bit.
You can also view a pair
of ordinary classical bits in the correlated
probabilistic state from before as being a resource which is
one bit of shared randomness.
It can be very useful in
cryptography to share a random bit with somebody presuming
that nobody else knows what that bit is so that it
can be used as a private key
or as part of a private key, for example, for the sake of encryption.
But in this lesson, our focus will be on this entangled state and
things that we can do with it.
And just to clarify the terminology, when we say that Alice
and Bob share an e-bit, what we mean is that
Alice has a qubit named A,
Bob has a qubit named B, and together the pair A, B
is in the Phi plus state.
It's not important what names
we choose for the two Qubits, of course, we could
choose different names, but throughout this lesson,
we'll stick with these names
in the interest of clarity. The first example of the lesson
is quantum teleportation,
which hereafter we'll just
refer to as teleportation for the sake of brevity.
What teleportation is is a protocol that allows a sender to
transmit quantum information to a receiver using only entanglement
and classical communication to
accomplish that transmission.
It has absolutely nothing to do with the typical interpretation
of the word teleportation in science fiction, which
is that matter disappears
at one location and appears in another.
Quantum teleportation is just a name that's meant to conjure that as an image or as a metaphor so to speak.
What's getting teleported is
quantum information not matter, and that's happening
through a transmission of classical information
together with entanglement.
To understand exactly
how teleportation works, it's helpful to begin by
setting the stage, so to speak.
What we'll do is to imagine a scenario involving Alice and Bob and
that scenario is as follows,
Alice has a qubit named Q that
she would like to transmit to Bob, meaning that she
wants Bob to hold in his hands
a qubit that's in exactly
the same state that Q is in as they begin the protocol.
In other words, we're talking about the fundamental problem of
information transmission or communication.
We have a sender named Alice
and a receiver named Bob and Alice wants to send
quantum information in the form of a qubit to Bob.
There is a constraint, however, which is that Alice is not
able to physically send Q to Bob, all that she can do is to send classical information to Bob.
Alice and Bob also have
an additional resource, which is that they share an e-bit.
So that's the scenario, it's
easy to imagine situations where the constraint that
Alice can't physically send Q
to Bob is a reasonable abstraction.
If Alice and Bob were on
different continents for instance, or if Alice didn't know
Bob's exact location, then physically sending a qubit
would probably be pretty challenging.
But classical communication
is of course not only possible but quite inexpensive
under those circumstances.
Now, one might ask whether it's possible for Alice and Bob to accomplish this task without even needing the shared e-bit.
In other words, is there
any way to transmit a qubit using classical
communication alone?
The answer is no, it's not possible to transmit quantum information using classical communication alone, and that's not too difficult to prove
using some basic quantum
information theory, which we'll see in the
third unit of the series.
For now, an intuitive
way to think about it is to think about the no-cloning theorem.